it's been over a decade since you won
Project Runway and now you're a producer
on the show we're here celebrating the
show tonight how does it feel to be part
of that it's cool um yeah it's a funny
thing it's like very very full circle
but it's great no it's been really great
and um everybody's amazing and it's you
know feels very different because it is
so different but still feel the same
kind of nostalgia which is really nice
the secret and really making it your
guys's own show I guess for me and my
kind of perspective on it is that I just
am very real I treat the designers
exactly how I treat my team I try to
give them real-world opinions and advice
as best as I can whether they want it or
not yeah so I think that's how you know
we try to make it I think I make it my
own there and I think the judges
probably do the same ask you about your
good friend selma blair who's been so
brave how is she doing first of all yeah
she's doing uh me I mean she's amazing
she's so strong and obviously everybody
has good days and bad days and yeah but
but she's just the best and I think you
guys have both commented on it actually
that you're maybe gonna do some sort of
fashion collaboration a collection where
where does that stand I don't know I
hope I hope we can figure out something
she really wants to do something I think
we just have to wait til she gets a
little better that we can like actually
really talk about it but hopefully I
mean I there is a need you know it's
like you
it's like someone like her she's like I
can't zip anything up like and I didn't
think about that and that's a really
interesting thing concepts to think
about to think like a you can't button
your jacket not a funny thing so yeah so
all these little things we'll see have
you guys actually like talked about it
recently though um just at a dinner
maybe a few months a few months ago but
that's it uh wedding season is upon us
changing subjects a little bit any
celebrities that you would just die to
dress on their wedding day Katy Perry
sophie Turner
none of them no no laughs Anna normal
people already are difficult brides
I can't imagine no actually I think
someone like Katy will be easier
like how she's worn Amelia she dresses
she changed they're out four five times
a day like she's used to it so I think
Katy would be cool I mean Sophie the
same you know stunning no I never think
about it I've done some really cool you
know dresses in my day and I don't know
I'm open to anything you're close with
Michelle Obama you've dressed her before
her style lately like post White House
has been out of this world phenomenal
what do you make of it she can wear
anything I mean Meredith and her stylist
is so amazing and I think now she's
loved fashion always had I think now
even more so she's like it doesn't
matter I can wear whatever I want to
wear which is which is amazing it's what
you want to see last thing I have a
question for you is that I don't know
it's not I have no idea what that is
I know it is no because a lot of people
said like oh is this yours and I don't I
don't think so but I really honestly
can't remember because you know Taylor
has shoots things so far far in advance
at planned so honestly but if I'm pretty
sure now you know why I think it is you
though yeah I feel like you know I did
an ombre beautiful dress but I but it's
not this yeah I've done two dresses for
her in the past for music video I have
yeah I have but we're working on
something for her but in a different
capacity what are you working on from
her to tell you a different capacity
come on no who knows she might wear to
the grocery store I don't know do you
think of all the hints that she's been
leaving on her Instagram I like that
she's doing that I think it's really
cool I think it's like a nice way to
give her fans something but obviously
she can't really reveal so I always
think it's really cool when artists do
that are you dressing anyone for the Met
Gala yeah we have a few people and so
yeah it's a lot of work it's a fun theme
though yeah it's Taylor one of them yeah
No
I wish but thank you so much a pleasure
yeah have fun tonight